can't shake himself he did a great job
of this so good morning everybody
it is my pleasure to introduce mort's
Hart from Berkeley who is gonna give us
a fireside chat about deep learning
thanks Ben
I thought because it's 9:00 in the
morning and you know people might not be
fully awake yet I was going to talk
about it a little bit of philosophy to
frame my talk and the technical part of
the talk is going to connect with what
the excellent talk dead super it gave
yesterday I don't know where he is now
he I just saw him like a moment ago but
yeah so I'm going to be connecting on
some of what he said and also tenures
talk from Monday so that's going to be
the technical side of the talk but I
want to start out while preparing the
talk it sort of occurred to me that I
don't really know what world what
optimization world will actually live in
and what you know the current sort of
flurry of results what it actually
suggests about which of these worlds
would live in okay so let me give you
four plausible worlds that I think I
would like to figure out which one we're
actually in and this is inspired by by
impact lay out those four worlds do
people know imp ugly as this world's
some someone do the complexity theorists
nod so if you haven't seen this there's
a 1990 1995 paper by in Puglia so that I
highly recommend I can't remember it was
five whirls and two of them collapsed or
four worlds to begin with five but two
of them collapsed right okay so there
might be collapsing world today we'll
see and so the first world that I think
for a long time people assume we're sort
of in is what I call convex Eco okay and
in convex ago there was sort of a
dichotomy which is that you know
learning is either hard or it can be can
be posed
as can be post as a convex problem right
and I think you know a lot of people
maybe also in this room up until like
maybe five years ago would have argued
that we're maybe in this world right
been or we might be still in that world
okay so you know I agree with you so
this was like a very compelling world
because it's it was mathematically
beautiful and simple and you know it'd
be nice if it were in that world but
like seems today most people are
starting to believe in the world I
called gradient inna where you know
learning is either hard or it's solved
by stochastic gradient descent okay
so learning is either wall that's not
good oh my god no balls in this talk
learning is either hard or solved by SGD
okay and this is the world Marty so
something that separating these worlds
you mean all right you know you I don't
right I'm not saying they're just
indistinct I'm saying here for plausible
candidates they might collapse as I said
you know somebody might prove that you
know whenever you know you have some
nice optimization landscape you can
actually also approximate it by convex
program and so gradient inna might
collapse to convex it go but for now for
all I know they could be different right
and so gradient inna is the world where
you know like we have things like you
know optimization functions that look
like this
right where you know there is a you know
there's a global minimum but there also
you know points where the gradient
vanishes or or where look at the
gradient gets very small and it's not
convex but overall you sort of you can
still run gradient descent it might even
be the case that you know you have
multiple you know global minima but
they're both good right so they both
like that's with an epsilon of optimal
okay but you're not going to have these
things where there are lots of these bad
local minima that have poor value and
you might get stuck in them okay and you
could argue that somehow these talks
that we've been seeing and all these
results that have been coming out on you
know pseudo convexity of this and that
objective function and all the things
that ten you talked about and some of
the things super talked about that there
are evidence that we we live in gradient
'inna okay let me just mention two other
worlds before you know get back to this
one so we revisit that thought the other
two worlds and maybe we're not going to
even gonna write them out but the other
two worlds are sort of you know you
could call them like octo Pia is the
next one where you know there's like a
yet to be discovered
you know optimization method that's
going to improve learning radically and
you know we're not going to be doing SGD
but like a few years from now there's
gonna be some other thing that it's
going to take over su d and gonna learn
all sorts of problems that we currently
can't learn okay and I think in the you
know and some people would argue that
this is probably the whirlwind right so
if you listen to recent interviews by
say Jeff intend he says you know SGD has
sort of run its course and there's going
to be something better that's closer to
how the brain works and that's gonna
solve problems that we currently can't
currently cancel right and you know
we're sort of we've reached the limits
of this paradigm but good thing there's
like some other clever optimization
method that's going to replace it and
it's going to be much better okay so
that's opto Pia it's also plausible and
the final world that you know impact Lee
also called pecci land but I'm gonna
call messy land
it's that sort of learning happens for
no good reason right it's just kind of
it's going to be messy right there's not
going to be like a great explanation of
you know why deep learning works and
we're just you know we're trying to find
an explanation where there isn't any
it's just going to be messy and you know
sometimes learning works sometimes it
doesn't and it depends on the random
seed you have to optimize the random
seed Ben likes that a lot and
reinforcement learning when people are
you know too hyper parameter search over
the random seeds and so you know that's
sort of like you could see that you know
if reinforcement learning works deeper
enforcement learning it might actually
be sort of you know over here and messy
land where things are just really tricky
and delicate and you need to work really
hard to get them going but you know in
principle learning can continue to
improve it's just going to be in like a
really messy way okay and there's just
not going to be a lot to do for a theory
and so like I kind of want to get a
sense by sort of show of hands what
people believe in you know which world
they believe in I kind of I chose these
worlds in such a way that I have a
uniform prior over them so I think
they're all they're all equally likely
to me so let's see who here still
believes in convex ago Maadi for sure
the theorists over there Ben of course
okay good number who things were in
gradient Tina also Maddie he thinks
they're the same also been good points
oh okay maybe we can collapse these two
worlds
where's Barcia go what margin margin Vil
okay that's a town in up topia who
believes in October that were optimist
everywhere you know that's good and
who believes in Massillon okay then you
can't just like always in there I don't
think like convex Eco can be consistent
with messy land oh really
no no because this seems like a very
clean explanation of you know like a
clean dichotomy so here's sort of the
like how the singularity would happen in
messy land right so this thing all right
seriously like the singularity and messy
land happens because you know sort of us
theoreticians run out of steam and we
don't know what's going on but good
thing the machines actually start tuning
themselves and they find these like
really complicated you know things that
do something and you know continue to
improve but we just can't scrutinize
them anymore and we can't understand
them anymore but they continue to
improve right so so but messy land I
don't just mean like you know you're
going to solve problems case-by-case you
may not even have a principled solution
right in algorithms you have like lots
of you know algorithms with guarantees
and and many different principles and so
yeah there were so many like principles
that might get messy but at least there
is like in every case there's a good
explanation right and so maybe we're
like really you know in this world where
we were not going to have a good
explanation sorry maybe I missed the
kind of way that it seems rule each
other out but certainly there will be a
large class of things in those first two
cases and we understand a large class of
things in those first two cases and
maybe there will be some other things
like a few extra special cases which
just work because people work good it
out all right but right now for instance
like when it comes to deep learning we
don't know if deep learning we certainly
don't know if it fits in here we
certainly don't know if it fits in here
because we
haven't even found like we haven't
improved that gradient descent works on
natural deep learning objectives my
friend into opt OPR where it fits into
you know my ceilin so like when we ask
like what does deep learning suggest
right the this flurry of results from
deep learning you know what is it
evidence off it's not clear the thing I
wanna sort of the question when I ask is
like the current sort of phenomenology
of things what is it
which world is it evidence off like you
what what we're observing in deep
learning right like both the theoretical
results that you know people are
starting to prove and the empirical
success which world is suggested by that
this is certainly not a mathematical
statement depending on the learning task
like you to do in classification or
something that could be in yeah that's
that sort of it could be that you know
you know vision tasks are just more so
robustly solvable and we can solve them
with provably solve them with gradient
method methods and you know for sequence
learning we can but in that case I would
actually interpret this as evidence that
probably sequence learning when it works
can be approximated by you know either P
forward or it can be approximated by
gradient methods so I think it does just
sort of says something about sequence
learning maybe not being as feasible as
we think it is
I thought I think that's tricky here and
this is the part that I'm just going
back to Paulo's comment is is the kind
of evidence that we get from machine
learning is not particularly scientific
so it's hard to wrap our heads around I
agree right it's just like I did this
and I saw why and they're not really a
way that get to principles all right so
I want to you know move on to sort of
asking let's say we're in gradient eana
right and we're what would sort of have
to be the case for you know for this to
be a plausible world right I think the
easiest way we could establish that
we're in this world is by saying that
you know essentially for most
interesting learning problems we don't
have vanishing gradients okay so there
are no vanishing gradients which means
that you know if for our objective
function the the gradients get very
small and what was this epsilon
stationarity is I think what Zuber
called it yesterday then you know
actually X is
most optimal okay so that you know we
can always like reaper amma tries the
problem or change the objective function
in a way that if our gradients disappear
then actually we're we've solved the
problem okay so we've gotten zero
training error or you know the objective
is actually small and so you saw from
tenures talk what thing you talked about
this usually happens for like matrix
factorization if you optimize an actor
eyespace you know you're trying to find
some matrix factorization like this
subject to some constraints could be
matrix completion or other things it
happens for some extent for tensor
factorization
and Benton you and I had a result where
we showed happens four linear dynamical
systems
and today I want to talk about the case
of residual networks
and this was we did this this will John
worked with also with 10 you from this
year and I clear and we're not going to
show this for like sort of non-convex or
we're not gonna show this for you know
sort of the fully general case of
residual networks we only gonna capture
it in like a very special case which are
linearized residual networks I'm gonna
tell you in a moment what those are okay
but like I think though like the sort of
the overarching question is you know
what do these what do these these
results really tell us okay so are they
evidence that you know when learning is
feasible it's actually feasible by a
gradient method first order local optima
for now no hazards okay so I'm gonna I
want to start with sort of the strongest
possible claim like you know you don't
have vanishing gradients you know you
there might vanish and we still have a
chance to cope with that through you
know there was research that Ben really
likes and so oh yeah or you know even
like eigenvalues have like saddle points
and you can still solve them right I
want to be liberal and like you know
including problems in this list so you
know you can throw an ICA or Nagin
values and so on but don't tell Ben
about it you know you you think saddle
points are not after all there you go
proof by invoking Ben yeah sorry yeah
and so anyway so this is over what
happened and in 10 years talk you know
where 10 you talked about it and give
you some examples about and so you know
these are like theoretical results
people I have proved there's also been a
lot of work in deep learning on the
empirical side on avoiding vanishing
gradients okay and we just had an exam
at Berkeley where everybody was asked
can I reveal this
no yeah you asked we have to publish it
so yes you have to publish it okay
everybody's asked you know something
about vanishing gradients and what you
can do about it and you know the right
answer with something like don't use
sigmoid transfer units use values okay
so well you know the answer yeah like it
was sort of like oh you have a sigmoid
neural network and you know I may be
oversimplifying this a little bit but
yeah it was basically the answer to like
avoiding vanishing gradients was to use
values instead of sigmoids and the other
the other the other answer was or you
know like one of the early papers that
addressed vanishing gradients was the
Ellis TM paper by co-writer and youtuber
from what 97 or something like that so
this was in the context of recurrent
networks where they said okay we're
going to do some extra circuitry called
the gating mechanism that's supposed to
ensure that you know great and still
vanish too quickly okay and so you know
but then it also inspired a lot more
recent work there are things like batch
norm that's widely used in all in all in
most vision architectures and you know
batch norm can be seen as a way of
trying to you know avoid vanishing
gradients and you know empirically
certainly I think a breakthrough was
residual networks which really did
something and you could now start to
optimize things that had like thousand
layers and and you know really things
that you couldn't do before
okay so deep learning can sort of be
seen as this very active area that you
know explores the space of how you can
change the architecture how you can
change the parameterization of your
problem to make the optimization
landscape more benign without affecting
the expressivity of your model I think
that's kind of what you're trying to do
there and so let me just you know as a
warm-up example talk about values and
why they don't actually avoid vanish
ingredients so suppose you have some
neural network and it uses you know
these this is a layer
l and what the layer does it applies a
rail you coordinate wise to a linear
transformation a of the previous layer
okay so Sigma is just max with zero
Sigma X its max with zero and coordinate
was okay people understand value and so
you know let's say you know your h0 is
something it's some vector or something
so what do you think happens when you
compute like your partial derivatives of
you know HL with respect to some faraway
layer h1 let's say people have a sense
of what what's going to happen backdrop
exercise you can do back prop at 9:00 in
the morning in their head across
arbitrate number of layers layer by
layer right so you're gonna get some
like transformation for that what's the
derivative over value so I guess well
use like 0 over here and then goes up
what's the derivative it's a step
function right so you're like it's your
here and one there okay and so like this
the derivative of this value has the
property that it's zero it zeros out all
the negative coordinates so whatever
vector it gets it's going to 0 at all
the negative coordinates right and you
know like so basically you're going to
get these products of matrices let's
write this as you know di and AI
transpose where di is a diagonal matrix
that comes from the Lu and it's just
that I open L given by the indicator
vector of whether HL is greater than 0
so it's going to be 1 in the coordinates
that are non-negative and it's going to
be 0 in the other coordinates so this is
just a diagonal matrix and here you just
ate great
oh no so the derivative is one if the
number is greater than zero and zero
otherwise it's just the indicator of
whether that depends on how you define
your value I don't know which one either
I'm fine either way this one doesn't
matter but you can make strictly
positive okay so you get these diagonal
matrices which is zero some of your
coordinates namely all the negative ones
and you just have a linear
transformation right and some other
stuff okay but basically you get this
chain of linear operations a diagonal
operation that zeros out all the
negative coordinates and just a linear
operation and so now suppose you're a I
it's just a random Gaussian matrix or a
random rotation or something like that
so it's always going to make half of the
coordinates 0 and negative right so you
start with an arbitrary vector and you
know let's say this is a rotation matrix
so it looks like this for some randomly
chosen basis you let say it's just a
rotation so it's going to take any
vector and it's going to rotate it
randomly such that half the coordinates
become negative right so your
understanding of a rotation random
rotation is full rank matrix it's just a
random rotation
why about the rotation to a vector you
you don't get zeros now get serious you
get negative coordinates right right so
if you apply a random rotation to a
vector half of the coordinates become
negative and so so if you apply random
rotation to a vector half the
coordinates become negative so half of
the norm is going to be in the negative
part and so half of the norm is going to
get zeroed out by this di operation all
right so at every step of this chain of
linear operations you decrease the norm
by a factor of two okay so rally your
networks actually are sort of the
definition of vanishing gradient since I
got every at every layer you slash the
norm by a factor of two so you have K
layers and the norm goes from you know
one to two to the negative K so rallies
don't actually address the banished
ingredients but we're gonna see that you
know I'm trying to try to convince you
that in this talk that residual networks
actually do seem to avoid them both in
theory and an experiment so is there a
wiper so let me tell you about but but
then you have exploding gradients right
right like you need to discern all right
what I'm saying is it's not it's not
prove that your vanishing grains but it
like it remains sort of something you
need to worry about right like even if
you just randomly initialize your
matrices at initialization it's already
a problem okay I agree you can be like
address with scaling and renormalization
that's why you know people couple it
with batch norm and then this kind of
goes away and you know there are ways of
coping but
all at the same level there goes away
will not all be independent the gate
please right but like at every at every
step you get a fresh transformation
right so it doesn't but yeah once you
run gradient descent you do correlate
them I agree that but like if we're now
even like the starting point is random
let's just consider starting point once
you run gradient descent you're going to
correlate things weirdly but yeah it's
even stuck or at the start even like
things they're gonna get small unless
you do something else about it right but
values alone are not gonna do the trick
okay so let me talk about residual
networks so how do residual networks try
to address this problem and this really
doesn't work
work with a wiper like this better okay
anyway so let's talk about residual
networks how many people have heard that
term before about half probably so the
idea of residual network is that if you
have something deep if you have like a
composition of many layers you gotta try
to like make every layer be close to the
identity okay so if you saw this you
know where was our previous description
this was sort of a standard network you
applied some non-linearity to some you
know linear transformation at every step
in a residual Network what you would do
is HL would look like this it would you
know again do the same thing apply
non-linearity to like linear
transformation of the previous layer but
it would also preserve the previous
layer by just adding it back in okay
let's say these these are all dimension
preserving this linear transformations
dimension preserving what it's going to
do is it's just going to apply this the
circuitry to the previous layer but it's
also going to you know preserve the
previous layer by just adding it in okay
so pictorially your a gel layer L minus
one layer and you're just going to copy
it and here you apply some circuitry to
it you know some circuit and now you're
just going to add it okay this is sort
of what it looks like for a residual
networking okay and this makes a lot of
sense to me because now locally
everything is kind of well conditioned
okay locally everything is close to the
identity every single transformation
that you do it's just a small change of
the identity assuming this is sort of
small norm
okay and this is usually how you
parameterize these things okay so you're
going to say look if you have a network
with like a thousand layers
it'd be really unfortunate if like the
last layer you know did this radical
transformation of the input right so
that's just like you know we probably
already have a good transformation let's
just change it a little bit okay let's
be conservative and how we change our
transformation our representation yeah
you learn it with this week sharing for
that for for like if this is like the
according to the you know depth of uh or
an unrolled yeah but a similar argument
is also would also work throughout
running gradient descent or is it would
it be equivalent to just think of
initializing they never considered
random rotation that you specialize to
identity plus a small right very good
very good so in the linear case that's
those are equivalent very good very good
observation so like if you don't have a
non-linearity here let's say you know
you just have a linear transformation no
non-linearity then your observations
absolutely right it's actually if you if
you didn't have a non-linearity here it
would just be a different way of
initializing the network and exactly in
the way you said by initializing it
close to the identity instead of just
close to zero okay yeah so let me also
mention for completeness this is not
usually the building block you have
usually the building block you have
looks more like this you have two linear
transformations you and value in the
middle and a V here this is the most
common building block and maybe there's
a bias term here and there was another
bias term here but basically you know
it's the same idea you have some circuit
here some circuitry but in the end you
preserve the previous layer okay so I'm
gonna ignore this for the moment and so
what we're going to analyze is actually
not the this general case where you have
nonlinearities we're going to be very
you know a lot less ambitious in this
talk and we're just going to analyze the
linear case where you know I remove the
Sigma so I just have HL minus 1 plus
Sigma times
sorry know Sigma times al times BH at
all minus 1 F plus KL times H 0 minus 1
okay and so the whole model can just be
written as a composition of matrices
like this
okay so my whole problem or my whole
architecture just becomes a chain of
linear operations where each operation
is close to the identity in the linear
case I just parameterize you know a
linear map in a weird way in this like
extremely redundant way okay so I have
you know L operations instead of just
one and each of them is close to the
identity
so it not very small right so let me
tell you what small means which one was
the good one this one and claims this
one is better
yeah totally a different game it just
sort of has this energy check that we're
sort of on the right track
imagine we try to do this argument for
residual networks in that case what you
would get is you get a product of
transformations like this some diagonal
matrix times some linear transformation
and of course this doesn't have the
issue it's not it doesn't shrink the
norm that preserves the norm roughly
okay so at least as a sanity check it
avoids the issue that I pointed out with
relyon networks all right and so we can
study with this linear version of the
problem we can study a regression
problem where I'm trying to learn the
linear map are from you know Rd to Rd
and my problem looks something like this
I want to you know minimize you know rx
that's it that's right like this I want
to minimize Y minus y hats and the
squared norm where Y is just equal to R
X plus some noise and Y hat is equal to
my residual model times X and I assumed
that X Y are drawn from sorry I assumed
that X is drawn from some distribution
some distribution with covariance matrix
Sigma doesn't have to be that's the only
thing I'm going to assume is that I know
the compare matrix Sigma and the noise
is Gaussian okay so I'm just considering
a standard least squares regression
problem where I parameterize my model my
linear model to be of this residual
shape does that make sense the problem
definition so now let me ask these or
obvious question is there's a convex
problem and so I'm minimizing over these
matrices a all up to a-1
is this problem convex
you know this sort of looks convex red
because of the squared last year but
then if you look at my model parameters
they actually come in is really weird
factor shape are is fixed yeah these are
my variables al through a1 are my
variables that's right that's right
that's uh sorry what of course yeah I
could just have a single linear or
transformation it's a you know I'm
solving a toy problem right it's like I
could just replace this by single linear
transformation and becomes convex a
certain teacher
capital D system distributions just some
X's just drawn from some distribution
with covariance Sigma right so you know
I'm gonna introduce like a sort of a
norm constraint I'm going to restrict
the spectral norm to be less than 1/2
let's say and at this point it's not
even clear that I can you know Express
are right so let me tell you I know what
circumstances you can express are and
this is just kind of some matrix algebra
which probably most of you will be able
to see so suppose our as PSD and I want
to write R as a product of many things
close to the identity let's say the
spectral norm of R is equal to 1 and
it's PSD how can I write this as a you
know as a product of L matrices that are
each close to the identity yeah so I
could for example set AI equal to you
know are the Alfred of R minus the
identity right this would do the trick
but it's not unique right I could for
example set a 1 equal to like 2 over L
minus I and then compensate for it in
the other transformations right so just
as a remark it's not it's not like
there's a unique solution here but there
is a solution in which you know I said
like this the spectral norm of AI is
order 1 over L right and so this is true
even in general for any linear
transformation are I can actually
express it in such a way I can express
it as a product of L things that each
close to the identity and by close I
mean order 1 over L
so in principle I don't even need half
here I could just use one over L
with the positive data deceptions right
so I can remove that right through the
proof just gets a little bit more
difficult but I can remove that it's
it's just the proof is obvious for a
positive definite and it's less obvious
for general matrices
okay so yeah I mean nobody has said that
yet but I think we agree that this is
not obviously convex right because you
know you have this factored space it is
sort of like a matrix factorization
problem and you kind of have a deep
factorization where you have all these
different terms and so this this
objective is actually not convex you can
check I think that's gonna make it
that's too strong an assumption yeah
in general because you're gonna
initialize these randomly or something
and so you they're not gonna have the
same basis as eigenbasis as are oh yeah
yeah and that's that's how are you gonna
prove that yeah yeah that's right right
okay so okay this is not convex but it's
actually you know fairly close to convex
and it's you know close to convex in the
sense that it doesn't have vanishing
gradients okay so let me state the exact
theorem so the theorem is the following
let I first have to define a region over
which I think the gradients don't vanish
so I'll call that B sub tau and piece of
tau is just the region where you know
the max of AI this is just a a one-upped
al all the a ones up to Al where the max
norm of any of them is bounded by 1 over
2 by tau ok so this is my domain and
over this region I can argue that any
critical point inside piece of tau must
also be a global minimum
and moreover I can give you an
expression for how large the gradient is
over this domain and the gradient norm
is going to be let me write as by a I'll
just denote the whole parameter said a
1/2 al I just didn't know if that's that
by a I can lower about the Frobenius
norm of this tensor by 4 L times 1 minus
tau to the 2 L minus 2 times the
smallest eigen value of the covariance
matrix of the input distribution you can
ignore that if you want for now and then
just how far I'm away from the optimum
so f of a minus C of opt where this is
the optimal solution and I guess I
should call this this is the objective
function so I'll call that F of a and
I'll call this whole set of parameters a
okay so let's interpret this real quick
if tau is something like 1 over L then 1
over you get 1 minus 1 over L to the L
so that's a constant times L and so this
basically like in the normal regime
where tau is equal to 1 over L this is
basically like Omega of let's also say
the conditioning is it's good so this is
just Omega of L times where this Omega
of F of a is co-opted
okay so just lower bounds the grading
norm by how far you're away from the
Optima and so the only way the graded
norm can get small is if you're actually
close to the Optima
the theorem statement clear you ever
changing defenders of Regis right that's
exactly right and I think that's the
game you're playing in deep learning
that you're changing the problem right
you you're not solving sort of so the
expressive power in this case is the
same I can express any linear map but I
just argued that I can express any
linear map this is the same expert civet
II I don't lose it has like in this
linear setting it has full expressivity
I can exit I can like I just argued
maybe I should have written this as a
lemma but that's right so yeah for for
like if I have only two things I
couldn't express anything but like if
the game and the residual networks is
that you make everything close to your
entity but you compensate for it by
making a deep thousands thousands of
layers so yeah I don't know but yeah
that's exactly right we're changing the
problem and that's that's the whole
point you know we're not solving sort of
the problem that might have bad critical
points we're going to a different
problem okay and so actually you can
rewrite the subjective function a little
bit that's kind of a simple lemma
and then the proof is almost over how
much time to up by the way I'm out of
time
really okay so sure I just make up rules
yes your ads oh no ok so again let me
just finish it up so you can really
easily rewrite the objective function as
something that doesn't have any
randomness inside so it just becomes
your your linear transformation I plus
al up to I plus a 1 minus R and we're
going to ignore the Sigma matrix for now
plus some constant okay so you can get
rid of the randomness and just write it
as how close are these linear
transformations in Frobenius norm this
is your model this is what you're trying
to learn how close are they're in for
being snowing so this is just equality
and it really simplifies the you know
objective function and once you have
that the proof is really over because
you just compute the gradients of this
thing and they you know you can really
read off exactly what's going on so if I
compute the you know the gradient of F
with respect to the iith matrix what I
get is just the following expression
it's just two times the identity plus a
I plus 1 transposed up to I plus al
transpose now comes my error matrix E
and this is just this guy how close am I
it's my error matrix call that e so you
multiply all these transformations by E
and now you transform multiply them from
the right by I plus a 1 transpose up to
I plus a I minus 1 transpose ok and you
know you don't really have to verify
whether this is true but the only thing
I want to remark is here's your error
matrix this is what you're trying to
minimize right and here you have a bunch
of invertible linear transformations ok
so the only way because all of these are
close to the end identity this is close
here they'll give you this closely
identity this closer than this close
indeed the only way that the gradient
can vanish is if the error term is 0 you
just stare at this at this expression
and
you know this has the smallest
eigenvalue if this guy is one minus one
over tau but one minus one over L the
smallest eigen value of this
transformation is one minus one over L
and same for all the others and so the
only thing that can vanish like if you
want your gradient to be zero the only
thing you can do only way you can make
that happen is by setting it to be zero
that's it
we can print it's completely symmetric
with respect to the hey ice right so why
is it that you get that right were
pretty mean symmetric with respect to
the yes there's no see they don't
commute they don't commute this is a
matrix product so the order is if you
can't rip them you know they don't
commute but the only point is if you're
right down the grading of this thing you
get something that can only vanish if
the error term is go by now really out
of time
[Applause]
where was the spectral norm I meant for
Venus so if you compute the Frobenius
norm of the this thing right then you
can lower bound this as sort of all
these Sigma mins you can lower bound to
surface times the Frobenius norm of e
what did I so this is the covariance
matrix not e I remove the covariance
matrix I just assumed its identity so I
mean from what to present it looks like
the conclusion is that you know you
believe more in current is not saying
that you so this is I guess if I had
more time I would have reflected or what
this tells us but so yeah it does this
like sort of the question is most people
interpret these kind of theorems as
evidence for gradient eana
but I don't actually believe that's true
because they don't actually get at
learning right so these are just
optimization results that talk about
critical points and they don't actually
talk about learning at all they don't
talk about generalization they tell you
nothing mode learning
so in some sense these these results are
you know at the very best sort of
circumstantial evidence for this world
but it's a completely consistent in my
opinion with also messy land or any
other of these worlds so I don't think
these results actually tell as much
[Applause]